Ja, 1000 Personen treffen die wirklich großen
Entscheidungen in diesem Land, ja.
Das sagt der Soziologe Michael Hartmann.
Er forscht zum Thema Eliten.
Und das ist sein Forschungsgegenstand:
die deutsche Wirtschaftselite.
Die Chefs der Dax-Konzerne.
Keine Frau dabei, die meisten
aus großbürgerlichen Verhältnissen.
Über ’n halbes Jahrhundert fast kommen
vier von fünf Vorstandsvorsitzenden
und Aufsichtsratsvorsitzenden aus den
oberen vier Prozent der Bevölkerung.
Da hat sich überhaupt nichts geändert.
Das variiert um ein,
zwei Prozent von Jahrzehnt zu Jahrzehnt.
Warum spielt Herkunft in Deutschland
immer noch so eine große Rolle?
Er hat eine Ahnung davon:
Serdest Demir kam erst mit acht Jahren
aus der Türkei nach Deutschland.
Er machte Abitur als Jahrgangsbester
und konnte dank Stipendien studieren –
als Erster aus seiner Familie.
An der Uni trifft er hauptsächlich
auf Söhne und Töchter
aus deutschen Akademikerhaushalten –
und die haben viele Vorteile.
Sie sind finanziell meist besser abgesichert.
Karrierefördernd ist häufig auch das
Beziehungsnetzwerk der Familie.
Und sie wachsen selbstverständlich
mit den Hobbys und Interessen
der oberen Schichten auf.
Und wenn man anders aufgewachsen ist?
Man muss das nicht als Schwäche sehen.
Ich glaub, da ist so ’ne große Gefahr für viele,
dass die sich dann nicht für gut genug halten
oder nicht mithalten können,
obwohl es – wie ich versuche zu betonen –
nicht ein Besser oder Schlechter ist,
sondern einfach nur ein Anders.
Ich glaub, die Kunst ist es,
sich selbst treu zu bleiben
und trotzdem seinen Weg zu gehen
und in diesem System eben voranzukommen.
Genau das Vorankommen aber
ist für Migranten- und Arbeiterkinder schwer.
Denn die Top-Positionen,
sagt der Eliteforscher,
werden nicht nur nach Leistung besetzt.
Es gilt das sogenannte Ähnlichkeitsprinzip.
Ähnlichkeit heißt:
Da sitzen seit Jahrzehnten große Männer
aus den oberen vier Prozent der Bevölkerung
– bürgerlich, großbürgerlich.
Die erkennen sich an der Sprache,
also dass sie den Genitiv
ordentlich verwenden statt Dativ.
Die erkennen sich an der
Selbstverständlichkeit,
mit der sie auftreten, an der Gestik.
Und die suchen im Grunde jemanden, der so
ist wie sie selbst, nur eben 20 Jahre jünger.
Ist er der Elite ähnlich genug?
Letztens meinte ’ne gute Freundin so:
„Ich weiß, dass du megaintelligent bist.
Und auch so von den Leistungen
und von der Art, worüber du redest.
Aber manchmal,
wenn man dich nicht kennen würde,
würd man auch auf den ersten Blick so
denken: So ey, wo kommt der denn her?“
Aus einer Einwandererfamilie,
in der das Geld sehr knapp war:
Uniabschluss und Promotion –
in seinem Umfeld ungewöhnlich.
Doch er will Karriere machen.
Was fair sein sollte,
ist eben die ... die Mobilität,
um von unten nach oben
aufsteigen zu können,
dass man, wenn man möchte,
dass man, wenn man den Drive hat,
auch die ganzen Sachen in einer Lebenszeit
sich zu eigen machen kann.
Die Chancen für den beruflichen Aufstieg
aber sind immer noch ungleich verteilt –
in ganz Europa – und die Eliten oft weit weg
von den Alltagssorgen aller anderen.
Das Problem, ’ne Mietwohnung zu finden,
haben viele von ihnen nie im Leben gehabt;
schon ihre Eltern nicht.
Sie haben ’ne andere ... ’nen anderen Bezug
zur normalen Lebensqualität.
Was für sie selbstverständlich ist,
ist für andere Luxus.
Wir haben ’ne Studie gemacht vor ’n paar
Jahren, und das Ergebnis war:
Je reicher und wohlhabender
Eliteangehörige aufgewachsen sind,
umso gerechter finden sie
die Unterschiede in der Gesellschaft.
Also, wer alles hat, findet es meist gut,
dass nicht alle das Gleiche haben.
Der Blick auf die Gesellschaft: abgehoben.